alright let's set it off right here so
let's just deal with you chuck how did
you feel with spike first approached you
to do the title song for this this
picture and then you guys to just double
double how did it happen
well there was a situation in New York
it was a lot of on surity unrest spike
said at a meeting that we had in
Manhattan I'm putting together a movie
that's gonna speak to this and things
have been swirling around in my mind and
also what we've been seeing for a while
I remember spike really saying at the
end of that conversation to myself bill
Stephanie Hank Shockley look dude I need
an anthem and Spike had already made so
many inroads just with he accomplished
the impossible and improbable by being a
film a black filmmaker from Brooklyn who
was in the middle of the social spears
fear with she's got to have it and then
school days so he was at the tip of
everybody's tone and discussion up to
the you know in that period of R&B and
that's Reagan and Bush
why you got to make a plane you see
black people in film and television
hardly I mean it was exceptions to the
rule but spike for the first time it was
like spikes putting together a flick and
everybody is on alert and when he said
look I'm gonna go to the next level and
I'm gonna discuss the undiscussed I'm
gonna be the voice for the voiceless and
we're gonna talk about this on the
covenant film Chuck Hank
Public Enemy I need an anthem and that's
all I remember I was in between tours I
was headed on tour in the Europe with
Run DMC and I remember before I left I
neither anthem now fast forward I know
that y'all fill in the blanks when I saw
the rough cut and and Brooklyn my whole
thing was like WTF who the hell puts the
song and I'm gonna be 20 times
I thought embarrassed because it wasn't
the final cut it wasn't the final track
but it was the thing that you had to go
in to fill the scenes right and I was
like dude I hope this to me no I just
think the cut and every time I heard I
kept getting sinking deep in my seat
like no that's not it that's not it but
the loss story real short fight the
power was the theme that really
discussed that white depart wasn't the
first one you submitted don't know know
but the theme of fight the power cuz you
wanted us to do lift every voice and
sing and we was like wow I don't know if
that's gonna fit and then Hank and I and
bill came up and said fight the power
but remember the theme you talked about
the film and he was saying a little bit
about things like the wall so this
would've Elvis and John Wayne thing
comes from because it was like they're
on the wall of being icons of America
the United States of America there on
the wall but the contributors are not on
the wall so it also led in all this
Blackwell's right in the song exactly
the boat did leaves a little Richards
and and Chuck Berry's along or just as
important to be on the wall as Elvis in
John Wayne so that's where it came from
but it really came from the discussion
the wall discussion and like really
spike you know
reiterated the fact that yo regardless
of what I said I need the anthem a small
pickup saying I need the anthem and come
up with it and there's a couple of
passes that came your way he was like I
need the anthem and that's just not it
well when I heard what happened I heard
fight the power though it was the second
fight the power let everybody know I'm a
musicologist and and and one thing about
filmmakers and John Singleton and and
Preston and people you know we're black
filmmaker that means you're well-rounded
in the arts all aspects of the arts
resonate in your creativity so you know
music you know music deep and Spike is
very deeply entrenched in Newton music
so we all knew about the first fight to
power by the eysies in 1975 right right
so you know if we don't if we don't know
now you know but that was the first song
I heard with a curse word in it right
because it was really speaking to all
the [ __ ] going down so that pretty
much is the theme of fight the power in
1989 to being reflective of do the right
thing
speaking about all the [ __ ] going
down and how do we handle it so I'm you
know people talk about this all time but
right I'm out the door but spike says it
wouldn't Bend they'll do the right thing
without fight the power it was true no
way in hell there would've been a fight
the power without do the right thing
which was I mean what really who the
hell puts a song in a movie 8 times
but every time rev our team showed up he
had his thing
it was blastin so that's why well you
know what it was helpful that it was
good so if it's great and it's good it
works and thinking about brother armor
thank you thank you